cet attentat qui heureusement on n'a
fait que des dégâts matériels mais
important tout de même pourrait être en
relation avec un conflit qui depuis près
de quatre ans maintenant oppose la
sonacotra un organisme chargé de
l'hébergement des travailleurs immigrés
à ses pensionnaires
une enquête de pierre chant petit à
garges les gonesse près de paris une
centaine de travailleurs immigrés
expulsés par la sonacotra campent depuis
trois mois au pied de leur ancien
logement
ils constituent le noyau dur d'une grève
commencée il ya quatre ans et qui a
touché presque tous les foyers
aujourd'hui encore dix mille résidents
refusent de payer leur loyer
la sonacotra est un organisme semi
public créé dans les années 60 pour
accueillir les étrangers venant
travailler en france c'est 300 foyers
situés en général dans les banlieues des
villes ou dans les zones industrielles
en abrite aujourd'hui un peu plus de
100000 certains travailleurs n'y restent
que quelques jours d'autres des années
ici le confort est sommaire
et pour loger tout le monde on a souvent
coupé les chambres en deux les prix 243
francs par mois pour quatre mètres
carrés 50 300 francs pour six mètres
carrés
si on calcule par rapport aux hlm qui
ont eux essayé des locataires pour un
essaim qui fait 100 mètres carrés il
paye 1300 francs tandis que nous pour 6
mètre carré par rapport aux hlm on paye
à peu près quatre fois plus chiant alors
nous ce qu'on demande aujourd'hui c'est
d'avoir un statut de locataire qui nous
permet bien sûr de savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on paye c'est à dire le prêt du local
et puis les charges alors à l'heure
actuelle on ne sait pas exactement
qu'escompté nous on estime qu'on n'est
pas des prisonniers dans six foyers de
création d'un contrat appellent les
palaces la sonacotra dit dans sa
publicité qu'il a menti il a construit
des foyers aux travailleurs immigrés
qu'ils étaient dans les bidonvilles
qu'aujourd'hui vous le papier les loyers
si le contraste complètement le
contraire à cyclo on demande non demande
de la liberté dans ses foyers
je crois qu'on réclame pas de dominer la
france notre niveau de remplacer
président de la république
autrement vous êtes d'accord sur le
principe de payer un loyer
automatiquement mais j'y suis en france
depuis 1953
j'ai toujours payé un loyer j'avais
dalle fois ils sont en contrat depuis
octobre 60 très simplement
alors je ne dis pas je paye pas de loyer
juste d'apporter un loyer mais schultz
en loyer juste ni plus ni moins
de son côté la sonacotra se défend de
faire payer trop cher car la redevance
qu'elle demande ne couvre pas seulement
le prix de la chambre mais aussi les
charges l'entretien le blanchissage et
surtout les espaces collectifs
sanitaires cuisine foyer que les
résidents oublie de citer quand ils
parlent de leur facture c'est aussi
parce qu'elle offre des services de
nature différente à la fois individuel
et collectif que la sonacotra estiment
impossible d'accorder à ses résidents
le statut de locataire qu'il réclame
seulement quand la réalité quotidienne
c'est vivre dans quatre mètres carrés 50
ces arguments du mal à prendre alors
depuis quatre ans l'épreuve de force
continue l'année dernière 20 mille
résidents faisait la grève des loyers
cet été 100 ans le mouvement faiblir la
sonacotra décide soudain de vider
l'abcès en faisant expulser les mauvais
payeurs
lorsqu on fait grève on sait qu'il ya
une contrepartie ion c'est lorsque ont
fait grève que l'employeur daf du
travail que l'employeur ne vous paiera
pas là il n'y avait aucune espèce de
contrepartie désavantageuse pour les
intéressés on ne payait pas et ont
continué à être logés ont continué à
être chauffés ont continué à avoir des
draps blancs qui ont continué à toutes
les fournitures d'eau froide ou chaude
sans qu'il y ait aucune espèce de
contrepartie désagréable doit
effectivement l'obligation aux nous dans
laquelle nous nous sommes trouvés
d'engager un certain nombre d'instances
auprès des tribunaux pour obtenir des
condamnations soit au paiement des
arriérés au paiement des sommes dues
soit à l'expulsion du foyer audel et
voyons bien que ces mesures que nous
avons demandé aux tribunaux et que les
tribunaux nous hantait nous ont accordé
ces mesures n'ont absolument aucun
caractère répressif
le rôle de la sonacotra n'est pas
d'excuser les résidents leurs lois et de
les loger c'est sa vocation profonde
mais néanmoins il fallait bien si nous
voulions endiguer le mouvement si nous
voulions éviter ça sa propagation mêmes
autant que possible obtenir un retour
général à la vie normale
il fallait bien que nous établissions
une contrepartie désagréable une
contrepartie de avantageuse pour les
résidents qui se réclamait de l'exercice
du droit de grève et vous êtes décidé à
continuer d expo nous n'en sommes bien
décidés je vous rappelle que nous avons
actuellement obtenus de long sont des
tribunaux de la région parisienne et de
l'est de la france
cinq mille décisions individuelles
d'expulsion nous n'avons fait exécuter
12 saut nous avons renoncé à l'exécuter
18 100 parce que nous avons réussi à
réaliser des accords avec
concernés d'où je sors d'exécuter 18/100
qu'elle nomme ronces et cela fait 3
milliards est encore jeune il a exécuté
nous sommes bien décidés dans les
semaines qui viennent avant la date du
1er décembre avant l'hiver officielle
pendant laquelle bien sûr les expulsions
ne se font pas nous sommes bien décidés
d'ici au 1er décembre à faire exécuter
les décisions d'expulsions que nous
aurons obtenu des tribunaux
reste à savoir si cette politique de
fermeté permettra de régler
pacifiquement ce conflit vieux de quatre
ans